you know on this show i share a lot of
my opinions on a wide variety of topics
some of those opinions are popular and
some
are unpopular i'd like to explore some
of those now in a segment called
unpopular opinion
this may be an unpopular opinion but
there should be an airline that's only
for adults i don't want any babies
crying on my plane the only crying on
the plane should be done by the flight
attendants
also if you're a baby where are you
going you're a baby
now this may be an unpopular opinion but
they need to stop making fast and
furious sequels just because it's the
name of the movie doesn't mean that's
how you should crank them out
now this may be an unpopular opinion but
the customer is not always right
we have to start giving workers the
right to say get your dumb ass out my
store
unpopular opinion i think james faked
his death on good times
unpopular opinion dinosaurs aren't cool
they're terrifying and i'm glad they're
all dead
real unpopular opinion elvis was not
that good he was just a mediocre white
man who had a little rhythm
sorry
now this may be an unpopular opinion but
i think everybody hated raymond and
everybody loved chris
if an episode of a show lasts longer
than an hour it's a movie
saying a mother and daughter could be
twins isn't the compliment you think it
is
if you have to play a slave in a movie
you should just automatically get an
oscar
and this may be an unpopular opinion but
i think this segment went extremely well
this has been unpopular opinion
[Music]
you